- Okay.
(soft music)
- How long have we been together?
- We've met like two years ago.
- We've been dating like five months.
- Around five months.
- Like ten months, nine, ten months.
We met through work.
- Well I met you on a booze cruise.
- I was organizing an event
and he was mentoring there.
- But you had been secretly
checking me out for a while.
- Yeah.
- We went full circle
to reorganize this event
and he actually helped this time.
- So he was the cute boy at work
and then I went to a bar with
my friend and she was like
just ask him out and I was like okay.
- And then we started dating like
a couple months ago this summer.
- When we both got to New York.
- So I Facebook messaged
him and we went out.
- Hmm, so.
- We met on Tinder.
(disk scratching)
- Yeah.
- I think I'm gonna do
pretty well, I know Claire.
pretty well because she wears
like a very distinct perfume, purple,
it smells like purple.
- Say I'm about 80%
confident I feel like I know
how my girlfriend smells
but you never know
until you get out there in the field.
- She smells floral, she
has a thing with flowers.
- Like sort of lavender-y smell,
yeah, I don't know.
- It's a little flowery,
a little sweet I guess.
She sprays me with her perfume
sometimes to be a pain.
- I'm going to completely ace this.
(laughing)
- If I'm wrong I probably
gonna be punished afterwards.
- If I'm wrong, I would
hope I'm not in trouble,
I hope it's a fun experiment
but you never know
when we get home tonight.
- Not the first time I've been asked that.
(soft sensual music)
- How far?
- To my left or right?
Not really good at describing smells.
- It's slightly sweet.
- not a lot of scent
there, I mean it's New York
so you kinda have to
discredit like subway funk
I feel like I'm gonna have to remove that
from every participant.
- She doesn't smell like that.
- I felt like some curly hair or something
which Claire does not have.
Maybe, I mean I leaned
in until I got a smell.
- Hmm hmm, she doesn't smell like that
it's not the smell I'm looking for.
- I don't think so, it could be though.
I'm feeling less confident
now that I'm here doing it.
- I smell something
familiar kind of floral.
- Hmm I, nah, a little more flowery,
but this is the last
participant so now I'm realizing
that I don't think any
of them are my girlfriend
I don't know if this is
some elaborate trick.
- I think this is, yeah, that's the one.
- I'm gonna say this is Claire.
- It's close I think between one and two.
- Yes.
- Ta-da!
- I'll go number one, did I get it?
Yeah!
- I smell like subway funk?
- I think I did pretty well.
- I'm like crying.
- It was an easy slam dunk.
- It was a close call,
honestly, between one and two
as I go on I move closer.
- There's that supreme court ruling
on pornography that
said I can't describe it
but I know it when I see it, you know,
same things with smells, I
can't describe the smells
but I know it when I smell it.